happy Tuesday reject nation I'm Greg
outlet I'm John Humphrey we got two
trailers this morning that drop so
expect a second upload in about an hour
to an hour and a half I guess they're
all trying to get some attention before
that embargo for Avengers end game
left's later on today bring us off with
Gemini man this is the Angley movie here
it has a plot kind of like looper it
stars William Smith and one of the best
youtubers in the world I loved his vlogs
that's how I know him yeah man
getting jiggy with it no no no no no na
na na na na na na my headphones are
tangled awkward Segway make sure to
download and follow us on the star ghost
app over there with you 30 second
reaction reviews for any film TV show
and/or trailer you can post your own
reactions on there as well we post daily
sometimes even micro sketches the entire
thing is completely free to download
completely free to use that's the
extension of the real rejects so make
sure to do it today
every move before I needed
oh right there
take the shot da get the Saab
who is he
[Music]
[Music]
as good as you is you
[Music]
you be a person of another person
me too Wow
[Music]
damn Wilson
oh this bikes coming in handy here David
Benioff mm-hmm elaborate John not
everyone knows who that is
oh is that one of the co-creators of the
game of thrones TV show there you go I'm
not sure how I feel about this movie me
neither
I mean I didn't really have anticipation
for it but I like I have this like bar
or something that I was expecting this
trailer to meet I was excited to hear
angley back
I'm excited he wrangling Will Smith I
feel like we're getting two kinds of
Will Smith
[Music]
there's a clone you got you know the
genre of Will Smith that I really like
which is sci-fi stuff like I am Legend
or you know I Robot and then and then
you have this the performance aspect of
him which is foreign to was something
like seven pounds or collateral Beauty
and who terrific was a little hey and
while I think even though I really
really like Will Smith the hell of a lot
I love Will Smith and I think Angley is
an amazing director I love that he's
always bold and always takes risks
especially in the way he chooses to make
his movies cuz this I heard his shot
with some special high frame rate or you
know I don't know if it's another Hobbit
scenario it feels a little bit more
specific you know I feel like it has
something to do with immersing you into
this world it's been a long time since
we've gotten you know one of these kind
of sci-fi clone action movies 6-day can
I recall something like that or
surrogates with bruises yeah that's I
think robot yeah it does have those
elements of you know a movie like looper
one thing that this trailer was missing
for me I mean they already got that cool
cover down you gotta have a whole
trailer recovers forever young brilliant
I don't know which you know with those
clone movies you they give you the
character to latch onto and I can't tell
if this is part of what makes this look
cool even with looper which is not a
clone movie but just a time travel movie
Joseph gordon-levitt's the one you're
latched onto yeah I'm not sure what you
will smith I'm rooting for Will Smith
I'm holding on to and I can't tell if
that's a good thing or a confusing thing
because I'm thinking on that's actually
kind of cool that like I like both of
these guys yeah or I'm kind of just
neutral about both of them because one
feels like well you know Bruce well this
is a bit much yeah I think about like
the movie the one which is a different
kind of clones or universes but like
when Will Smith his fighting Will Smith
in hand-to-hand combat I flashed today
because I think that's a really hard
cinematic thing to get down I feel like
you know the leak and capture that
pretty well Clive oh and definitely a
bad guy it seems like or he's in a
dubious moral standing either way
because you know he seems to have a very
personal relationship with Smith and
their relationship with Will Smith
they're going to have to have the whole
like you betrayed my trust you clone me
like what are you gonna do yes the
question is why well yes we gotta go in
there to find out apparently I mean
that's the thing is like I've been
intrigued to see what this movie would
look like obviously because of its
pedigree and the thing is I'm not really
getting much from it aside from the
premise at least in the dialog like
that's kind of what all of that side of
this trailer is dedicated to is just
sort of the central conflict of you
cloned me well yeah but that means that
you've got all this guy's skills without
any of his pain and stuff like that but
um you know the actual flavor of the
movie beyond that is really only coming
out to me and the action because it does
look somehow like the action scenes have
a different quality to them
well yeah young Will Smith really loves
to use that motorcycle
yeah the coolest action moments recycle
stuff yeah
reeling into a car I mean the cast is
supporting cast looks Mary Elizabeth
Winstead she's always good she's always
damn good wong wong realizing the game
yeah must be real easy on set it kind of
just looks like a cool sci-fi HBO action
movie but it also has this this tone
that is so yeah like so heavy but I feel
like I'm looking at a Will Smith movie I
just would have seen a few years ago
well yeah I feel like I'm watching like
a Bourne Identity or a looper type movie
but with of one of those you know seven
pounds type tones for some reason like
that's all the emotional beats I'm
getting have that quality to them but
maybe there's not really showcasing them
a lot in this trailer
it's gonna be way funnier I both Wilson
you know even though they're showing
like Will Smith looking tired crying a
lot I love the attention to detail it's
funny here I love the attention to
detail because the older Will Smith list
looks more like the modern-day Will
Smith obviously but then you have the
young wolf Smith who has like the
haircut yeah look we all know what young
Will Smith looks like now we got so we
need to make sure his haircut looks that
would classically on Will Smith that way
you're distracted by oh yeah that's my
new is on Freddie yeah exactly yeah man
game I'm kind of confused by the plot
too because they're saying that they
cloned you 20 so I guess this is a clone
movie and a time travel movie or or
maybe those clones don't age as
ridiculously fast as they're supposed to
in regular life there's got to be two
Clive out with your because one Clive
Owen looks a lot younger than the other
climbers giving this trailer yeah yeah
yeah looks like he has a much more
benevolent disposition I've never
noticed a little more robust now he's a
little more salt and pepper ease a
little more battle-worn
true this is a great time to transition
to a page in the day show love for that
I do want to say thank you for watching
what do you think of Gemini man guys
before in this video I want to do a page
in the day shaft for a man named Kurt
Anderson Kurt Anderson for some reason
this trailer just feels like you're the
rightful shout out oh I didn't see you
getting cloned and having to go up
against yourself you seem like you would
be up to that challenge yeah because he
is one of our older patrons who like
Will Smith is 75 but looks 25 he is such
a healthy human being yeah he's so
healthy and he does have some of that
salt and pepper sexy look going on to
him Silver Fox you must be on some curry
I'm always talking about how you're
traveling and on some crazy adventure
all the time maybe you are just trying
to find your younger self and murder him
I wouldn't put it past you and you have
to because you can't have that guy out
there just like living up your life and
stuff like that can be
metaphorical yeah maybe Kurt's not like
a traveling no man maybe Kurt's on the
run he won't ever have peace until he
annihilates his clone maybe that's the
key these are things I think about and
so should you Kurt especially if that is
your objective guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and check out soon